hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to spaghett now you may be
familiar with the meme somebody Thomas
but even though that meme is outdated
this game is a horror game yes that's
true I think anyway I actually don't
know let's play the game and find out
shall we look at this we get to see the
slur to see the slap sequence slap the
spigot by clicking the correct mouse
sequence in the sequence complete the
sequences to keep the spaghett warm try
to complete the first to keep it warm
somebody's slapping my spaghetti why do
I need to slap of this forget to keep it
warm whatever if that happens it's Oh
press a to continue you got it baby if
you click the incredibles button in a
sequence you'll punch the split this
will cause the temperature to drop and
complete the next four sequences Oh what
happens if I somebody is a fetish I
never even knew existed right now in the
top right corner of the screen there is
a visibility meter this meter fills
whenever an unwanted spectator watches
you if the meter fills completely you
lose alright let's avoid that look down
the arrow click left Luke to hide okay
well down there you can't be seen by
anyone on the other side of the counter
keep in mind that
were still exposed on your side do stand
up look at the arrows if you vent that
there is a threat on the side of the
counter you'll need to hide on the other
side to do so look at the jump across
try it out to return from that side
click jump back Oh plus a when you're
back behind the original side to counter
to continue oh it's so dynamic ah
this concludes the tutorial to see this
view you can enable it in the settings
menu press a to close oh okay oh [ __ ]
somebody did it touch you must forget
sorry I punch it up again all I wanted
to do was determine forget oh boy I'm
ranked 100 who's top 10 who's top 10 ten
seconds slapper
slapper - pappardelle we're gonna we're
gonna slim pinky this linguini
don't let mama see you I don't know did
mama make this
Oh Oh God okay all right I think that's
probably the good sound slap it is
Lapidus hmm stay away from Goldie what
about Papa Bear miss me baby stay baby
strikes what moves I move what are you
talking about moving when I see baby
what Papa hates being watched well Papa
no baby Papa baby this games tough okay
all right then I bet I can do that again
everybody welcome to super get mixed up
with Papa being something else
disgusting
what me slap with the do this forget I'm
pretty sure that it's not good for me
either but you know we can't all be
beggars of juicers flatus laughing okay
slap produce look at slap it slap it
slap what happens laughs laughs laughs
whoohoo
Papa hates being watched okay they're
stopping to watch papa
oh I'm looking alright um oh gone okay
so I assume that means you didn't want
to be looked at and apparently I do look
at you we have to write these these slap
sequences are getting complicated okay
that hiding meter don't go away
wait that's that's not fair the hiding
Weiner don't go away I can't hide my
wiener
I can't it's impossible to oh [ __ ] not
that disgusting I need to heat up my get
hay on wait whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
okay right left left right left left
left left right left left left left left
right right right right right right look
Oh wrong I thought you were gonna be
Goldilocks mmm this is gonna get got
left right laughs laughs right right
laughs right laughs right laughs laughs
laughs right laughs laughs laughs right
right right right left
hey buddy hey Baba hey papa hey nobody
touching your super can't nobody ever
touch left left left right right right
right right laughs oh that was a bit too
close for comfort
okay all right left right right right
left their mom is always watching it I'm
never gonna be able to get away from
Baba just let me touch it slap my
spaghetti Beast mama you told me you'd
knock before you come watch you never
know what I'm coming to slap my
spaghetti right with you papa and there
we go Papa no that was wrong that's it
oh man I'm gonna lose it I want to get
past five minutes
Oh Oh No
[Music]
okay all right all right let me slap let
me slap how can I slap if you be so
[ __ ] okay barely any barely any but my
oh my yes sitting couldn't so called
I don't know how hot my hands could
possibly be just okay we got charger
yeah I don't know what Goldilocks is
call me disgusting Goldilocks is the one
that came into a house full of bears and
decided to ruin everyone's day
[Music]
I did pretty good though I'm not gonna
land it pretty good I wanna see what
happens when I die from everybody I
don't think there's a way to actually
there's a way to actually win this I
think this is gonna be me slap until the
end of my days
hey baby maybe am I on the leaderboard
though wait no but I slept real good but
my slaps how can I saw okay welcome to
Ambur skull so amber skull is actually
an interesting game I found on Steam
that contains four different horror
experiences you've got the blizzard
you've got the forest you've got ocean
and you've got abandoned so the first
one oh I have to do the first one here
oh can I do can I ship oh no I have to
oh I guess we have to start with the
blizzard so we're gonna go with the blue
oh hi hello
I'm in a box or I'm in a cage or I'm in
a chimney
I'm Santa I'm seeing two stuck in a
chimney and this is how many days I've
been trapped here damn my perpetual life
all right then I'm out okay I'm back in
I'm out and I'm in alright I'm guessing
this is where I hide from whatever is
happening out here probably hide oh boy
Oh ping pong this is but I got a bad
feeling about it okay so says you so
says me let's go to it I guess I gotta
follow the bling clunky light I cannot
run far at all
okay it's getting dark oh my god well
can't run for sure yeah alright okay we
have to worry about look it okay alright
what that was why that was but it was a
good teaching lesson to know that I
wasn't close enough oh you did oh you
did code you're gonna be dickish to me
huh righty-ho I guess I gotta follow
these out and try to power up whatever
the hell that is
maybe there's some kind of rocket that
can get me out of here blast me off back
to the mainland it's my only assumption
here otherwise I'm just gonna be boned
around walking in the middle of the
freezing desert with nothing to my name
I'm guessing I did spend enough days
trapped in that little there's another
one but this one's got a plan it oh this
one's got a little planter on it I made
them please okay well c'est la vie I
made it through that I don't know what
else is gonna be waiting for me out here
but I don't think I needed to do that
I didn't hear a thump e1 so I'm guessing
I'm fine that's not good problem problem
problem problem problem we're in trouble
I don't know how to get across or down
oh I know how to get across an tower
down all right this seems good oh I was
just about to say it seemed safe I was
very wrong my heart go thumping some
people bowed my head okay hope you fall
down and die okay I guess he's not gonna
do either of those options all right
thank you thank you very much for that
all right cool anybody
did I hear I love you oh okay I forgot
that you just walk into it wonderful I'm
doing great so that's it this is a cool
thing about this game if there's four
different modes with apparently
different mechanics for each one that a
brutally spooky I don't know if it
counts as one game horror game or four I
mean the threat of death seems to be
pretty not immediate I mean it's
immediate there's a big ol Yeti after me
but it seems like there's playin safe
zones to possibly hide it no I can't run
run run run run please run okay alright
sorry okay alright so I guess I gotta
try to traverse the snowy terrain by
myself with no help of cord stop stop
just stop it
this job is not cool
my old heart can't take it me old pirate
heart oh there we go alright that's good
that's grand actually that's grand
god I'm feeling comfortable again I feel
as if nothing's gonna come out and jump
scare me I sure hope so up nothing do
cuz that would be that would be just a
big ol pile of hoof yeah I got lost
again got no it in front of me or beside
me oh there we go found the card and I
cannot run very far I guess it is winter
and I'm probably wearing a lot of
equipment oh oh oh
don't care going going going going run
more little more please ah
that was close
I made the right call by going back for
it I made the right call I made the
right call I made the right call made
the right call [ __ ] all right this
guy me why why why hey I found the
bunker okay okay I don't know what
happened I think I hit the button minute
war did it I think okay it's fine I
don't like everything goes dark whatever
I run also I have a funny feeling that
the the base is actually just very very
close and I'm running counter Wampus to
everything I need to run dude
it's edition yeah but what that's
what
oh is it you some piece up no you know
thump beats up real hard yeah I found a
cable I don't know if it's the cable oh
wait there it is okay I'm very close
I've almost got this I think they've got
it okay here we go I'm gonna push the
button push the big big button button I
push to be
we want yeah that was a lot better than
expected I'm sure am glad that the Yeti
climbed on top of my giant laser cannon
okay I don't like that okay it's
perfectly innocent sounding but let's go
stay in the light okay all right we're
gonna stay in the light
something tells me the forest is
knocking out flaming dildo okay
Oh looks problematic a giant rat man
apparently oh do I have to burn the
forest now oh my god it's a dream come
true what you think that that fire would
produce more light I didn't I don't know
what the hell huh okay that didn't make
any sense I was trying to say in the
light then there was no light and then I
didn't stand it actually didn't actually
stay in it okay now I have light now I
have some light but I didn't have light
before for some reason it was gone just
kind of there now I have I'm trying to
go okay you see how I have no light move
Tim going to go back let me go back with
its light and I can see things okay I
got I got light I gotta go I gotta go
okay all right let that
Dow's nice whoa
Oh ah it's a dead end
I'm gonna go back I'll go back okay
precious priceless read light okay I
hate this I hate this this is a
different force than any other words I
remember all right all right let's go
let's go for it
I think it's randomly generated hi okay
all right okay don't see anything in the
woods that time that's great okay all
right cool I don't know okay both are
dead ends both are dead ends go go go go
go back back back back back
I don't like being out of the safety of
the light the warm comforting light the
light is nice the light real nice okay
that's gonna take some time I'm gonna go
back well that's burning there's nothing
to be panicked about in this forest
everything that can arm me probably
won't harm me that's the solace that I
take for this go go go go go good
working girl all right oh good good I
heard that from over that way so I won't
be going that way
definitely not all right let's try it
this way okay so far so good so far so
good so far so yes hi hello oh it's the
Witch of the woods
it's the Blair Witch that's not so bad
I'm not gonna go that way though that
seems like a bad that seems like the
wrong raw
Oh oh no no no hello okay all right we
you don't need to do that we don't need
we don't need that we we don't need that
we just don't need that I we don't need
that is all what I have to say about
that bridge that's new um is it good do
I go across the bridge or is that just
instant death I love it I guess it's not
instant death okay hover bad mium no
when water bad water real bad
mium no go near water me I'm not gonna
your water
oh good pyre you know like water water
no good some people say water good B say
no water no good alright okay I don't
like any of these choices mmm okay let's
try one of these let's try one let's try
one okay not that one not that one not
that one let's not go that one that was
bad that was bad that was bad I didn't
like that one anyway maybe let's try
behind the rock the secret one behind
the rock that seems like that's good
nope never I'm not good not good very
bad actually very bad very bad very bad
okay you know what I had a good feeling
about this one down here on the left I
had a great feeling about this one so
let's go
okay still good still good still good
still good still good still good oh so
good so good my hearty thumpy thump real
good but it's okay alright only one way
to go after this oh no okay left just
guessing okay oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] going back
going back going back going back going
back going back yes made it okay still
alive we burned down the pile I'm
assuming that's the way that we need to
go now okay
go go go go oh my god so many splits no
oh no no I'm going back I don't care how
far it is I'm just gonna go back that's
white god I forgot to click there's got
to be the right way to go up here I just
burned a pile go go go go go go go go go
go go
I don't know where it's going to
sleeping back oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh no no
no no no no no no no no no no oh no come
on I don't like you I don't like when
you do that to me it's like a looping
back and forth bullshitty woody but at
least I burned a pile I think I did
let's go let's try to follow that but I
have no idea which way that went come on
come on please yes yes okay oh yay
hello mr. fungus man okay alright so
alright this bride the farda's I made it
I don't even know how who's got him
okay big pile alright big pile yay
that worked out quite well for me I
didn't think it was gonna end then it
worked out Oh guard unit unit okay all
right well that was game two of the
three games let's try ocean which I'm
probably going to hate hold signal
collect oh I'm probably gonna hate this
okay all right at least it's not based
on random chance hopefully oh oh no oh I
can move my boat okay but why though why
what's at the front of my boat oh no I
hate it I hate it but this is the worst
thing I've ever seen oh okay I'll go
towards the light cuz I've got nothing
better to do with my life yeah I just
know there's gonna be a giant Megalodon
shooting a shooting up out of the ocean
any time now
you it's a boy okay thanks boy do I hit
oh I'm out of gas oh I don't know what
to do what was that one okay why what
did I do wrong
I mean I just sat there for a long time
but what did I do wrong to you I didn't
even know how to start it up again dude
know how to start it out I hate that I
can't look behind me oh okay that's easy
enough I now know how to start it again
you just hold and click an old and let
go when it gets in the green
ha okay okay okay okay all right you
don't need to do that you don't need to
do anything to me I don't understand how
the mechanics work of this is it
rah Oh rocky waters do we go into it I
guess
I'm guessing we go into it hey maybe the
monster will have a tougher time trying
to get us if we just go into this I
think maybe
okay
I don't know if he's gonna help me at
all let's just eat one more I think okay
where could it ding okay where could it
possibly be yay I think when I get there
I'll be game over and I'll get to go
home and everything will be fine okay
I'm going towards something all right
not sure what that's slower no hey don't
do that okay so over here it's faster
towards it oh well there we are
oh please I don't think you need to be
anywhere near me right now
whatever's behind me does not mean to be
anywhere near I'm gonna make it in here
we're gonna be fine oh okay I don't know
what is this beep what did I do okay
I can't start it back up again I'll go
with the beat
okay
I win
I think I winder
[Music]
right we get to go to whatever abandon
is oh listen flash check alright I'm
ready to flash my tits I can do that if
it means I don't die I'll flash pretty
much anything I got oh oh oh no that
kind of flash oh I don't like it already
it's like five nights at frumpies in
here oh no idea what I did wrong was the
blood bad was the blood bad does the
blood mean bad
did the blood mean bad is bb4 bad blood
for bad let's not do that baby
what's with what whoa hey that's good
listen listen listen listen listen
listen listen listen
okay I will listen listen listen listen
okay okay all right well I can't tell
anything no open it's just a bad it's
getting my hair okay then
guess we gotta listen huh why is why is
it why why
nope nope no know who came up with this
sadistic game who made this sadistic
game it's not abandoned oh yeah there's
a light over there
[Music]
I almost died
how much choked okay I don't like the
way I don't like the way the movement
goes ah hate that hate that God I don't
know what that does but I got it I got a
beep boop okay what am I looking for
again and why why am I looking for
whatever I'm looking for I don't know
what I'm looking for why am I here why
would I be here why would anyone be here
what's what's the point of all this
oh why is it running like a potato why
is it capturing whoa oh [ __ ] hi okay all
right I don't know why it's going in
cinematic 24p but okay whatever you know
I'm I guess this is just how it is
that's blood I'm not gonna let's let's
not be for blood ah blood here too okay
but is there another door
good no blood no blood means fine right
yeah it's fine yeah okay I think I got
the recipe I saw blood I saw blood no
what no blood no blood
so it's either blood or sounds I don't
know what what for Oh bright in here
okay why why also why run like potato
why get two frames please have more
frames please I know this is it holy
[ __ ] okay okay I guess I go this way
okay great great great Greg Greg Greg
Greg Greg
okay slightly less potato way framerate
in here
still pretty potato II that was the
noise or not it wasn't sure okay let's
turn down the graphics on that
particular level alright let's do this
less and less and listen I can't see
[ __ ] well this is the worst I can this
is graphics or I gotta listen I gotta
listen hang on let me try try hi
okay let's do hi all right let's do hi
let's let's get high
okay all right okay how can I hear it if
you fake me out maybe I'm not close
enough to hear it I need to get farther
on the threshold blood blood
hey [ __ ] okay sometimes that just
happens so let's go down this one
sometimes that just happens a person
okay five Oh No
why I didn't hear I couldn't hear what
the [ __ ] all right here we go I think
this is gonna be the last one I can't
hear [ __ ] on any of them I've got no
ears on this
no no blood hey oh oh oh go away go away
go away yes please
whoa what is this
okay so man this is the sweetheart you
married the husband you expected him to
be as the war created new problems for
you in your marriage
to answer these and other personal
problems brought in by your friends and
neighbors Herod presents John J Anthony
founder of the famed marital relations
Institute in a brand new program of
daily sessions of kindly and helpful at
night what laugh is mr. Anthony Ryan
Applegate marriage advice I'm gonna play
this this is I don't know what this is
but I'm gonna play it hello
ooh nope don't like this oh hello hi am
I getting a new job oh that's a little
oh oh it's a bunch of simulations
that's the oculus rift testing facility
hey wow these are really cool what do
they do
Oh No how did someone gulag me please
don't strap me into one of those I don't
want to relive experiences or at all you
just suck out my brain is that what
happened people sucked out their
memories and put them onto these tapes
and that's what I was reliving I think
I'm being dragged but I'm not hung up
son sure oh oh no no don't suck out my
brain now my brain my precious brain
come on man oh please I don't wanna ask
weak
Oh No okay well there goes my brain
hello oh okay
all right what's happening calibrating
Oh
what do I do trying to move but no move
okay
oh hi hello how are you oh did I make it
out am i and I better this is [ __ ]
can't move
no I guess everything's all for the good
now everything's hunky Dukey I guess oh
oh there we go I'm up oh hey I'm up okay
well can I straighten that out again
no all right well then that's good I got
that from wherever I got and I live in a
[ __ ] but all right oh let's get out
of here that no never mind let's not
let's pick this up no let's not let's
look at this no let's not hello
um was that a gunshot probably yes okay
should I be worried about this urgent
you're trying to break down my heart
I'll open it for you
[Music]
okay dude literally no that was cool
I'm dead okay I'm dead all right well
that was still cool except for that
happening but that was cool
there's no joke really really cool four
games in one plus another game that's
not bad well thank you Charlie B hen for
making this Ben behind behind for making
this and thank you everybody so much for
watching this was a really cool one love
this a lot I liked how it was diverse
the forest one was a little [ __ ] but
I'll forgive that one the other ones
were still pretty cool but thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought down in the
comments below if you've got more scary
games that you want me to play let me
know in the comments as well thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]